but I really am up here um well hi
everybody is nice to see you y'all look
pretty good 17 years later thank you to
the HSPA for inviting me back to the
family reunion especially with all these
extraordinary ladies this year I mean it
your work moves me it moves me and I've
been cheering for y'all from theater
seats for a long time being on a list
with you is cool 2,000 years later who
thanks their agents first me Kevin who
vein vine Lord Peter Levine Nicole
Pernod Dom Appel Macy John Kirby no my
partners in crime I just have to thank
you for always reminding me that the top
doesn't matter six and a half hours
later it's the journey that matters and
the work that matters
thank you for always saying just do the
work or now just do the work thank you a
few inches later thank you thank you to
David Livingstone for that first call
Cameron a lot of people I'm gonna try
and squeeze it because he films from
making it um gosh Jeremy for all those
prosthetics you were just incredible
Matt Dinkley maestro Eric vitro Gary
catona Jeff Foster Paul is kicking me in
the pants make me try a little bit
harder
Jesse Buckley Fenwick Rock many months
later Finn went rock and Rufus I have to
tell you celebrating one of the great
icons of our time with you has been one
of my great life blessings and the
Condor
sessions that I have had with people
internationally we just want to express
their love for Judy Garland and tell
about the great personal significance of
her legacy and her humanity has been a
great reminder that the choices that we
make matter what we make matters and how
we choose to honor each other in our
lifetimes can matter a great deal down
the road thank you so much everybody
it's nice to see you avenge you Eddie
kill me anytime I'm not the English
man's whole career it's already right